their voyage w this must be the
sturdiest golf ever says our cart
estimate has karate made of granite it
becomes a symbol for the annual GTI meet
invite nits on Lake Bertuzzi Tomata says
he's here to discover what GTI fans are
up to and what there is to see I'm Dylan
guess two years or so Zack knob on
Vasquez Oh Susan get lots of gti's at
any rate and their fans many of whom
come here year after year
he has the option where's the GTI
capital Montes asks does it fit that's
certainly true for one weekend a year
when over 100,000 VW fans gather in the
small village in Austria they bring
their cars to even if it means pushing
them
since 2006 VW has been the main sponsor
of the event the automaker shows off the
latest prototypes like this wolfsburg
edition Golf GTI built by trainees the
city of Wolfsburg may not be much to
look at but the car named after it is a
real eye catcher Marcus says the meats
no longer just for gold fans almost all
of the VW Group's brands are here he
likes Audi stand which resembles a pit
length but what do these girls think
buddy medicines are not very talkative
montes decides to go and have a look at
Audi a3 clubsport quattro concept car
that's celebrating its world premiere
here based on the a3 sedan Audi's
Quattro division has created a sport
version of the car that's lower wider
and faster than the most powerful series
production model you know I descend a
high schooler vaguer from Audi Quattro
says people here are active in the
tuning scene and tinker with their cars
themselves so they know how much work
and attention to detail go into the show
cars and he says here you get a feel for
trends in the tuning scene and the
exchange which can be a bit crazy but
also expert is something you really only
find advertised a CVT do it I'm feel the
same and because many of the guests here
spend the night at campgrounds Audi has
brought along some useful gear a tent
that can be blown up quickly and
attached to the car this initial version
can be fastened to a q3
the latest offering from Spanish
automaker Zia might not be so practical
but it is definitely crashing it's cup
stir combines elements of a roadster a
small car and a sports car
that cup size ID this rib says the cups
there is an emotional interpretation of
se hace Beatson Leon cup racer and a
convertible he says they wanted to show
what they could do here people could
also play card table tennis an
interesting twist on pong the cold video
game of the 1980s
nearby oscoda visitors brave a go-kart
course on mini quads and capture the
action using a helmet camera
guests can also view the city jet part
small car part roadster it too was
designed and built by trainees not to be
missed are the daring drivers who
perform acrobatic maneuvers with their
vehicles and really burn rubber
Volkswagen supervisory board chairman
farad and I'm peeche was also on hand to
thank lighten its for granting him
honorary citizenship for the am Burger
Chef five nits was happy to show his
gratitude for the 20 million euros in
business the GTI me generates each year
but for visitors it's all about seeing
and being seen the flatbed of a midsize
pickup is the perfect place to party go
get Martha says here at the 33rd GTI
meet he's standing on an Amorite pick up
he claims it only goes 100 kilometers an
hour so it took the guys eight hours to
get here time audio cannot say he says
it only goes 90 kilometers an hour ok ok
90 motto says how could he have thought
otherwise but he says it's fun up here
and suggest they keep on party